اقبال كبير ومنافسه محتزمه مع مواصله
الامريكيين التصويت في انتخابات التجديد
النصفي للكونغرس حيث حتى كل من ترامب
وبيدن انصرهما على ضروره الخروج والتصويت
بقوه في الانتخابات وسط توقعات باكتساح
المنافسين الجمهوريين لها وبعد اذن
الناخبين باصواتهم اليوم قد يستغرق انتظار
نتائج ليله طويله وربما اياما قبل ان يتضح
ما اذا كان الجمهوريون او الديمقراطيون هم
من فازوا وسيطروا على القدره يتوقع كثيرون
موجه ضخمه من الدعم للحزب الجمهوري و ضغطا
كبيرا من الرئيس السابق ترامب كذلك وهو ما
يمكن ان يؤدي الى اعلان الجمهوريه مصر بعد
ساعات من اغلاق
ولكن عادته ولايات ان رئيسيه مثل سلفانيا
السابقت هذا الامر بالاعلان عن ان فرز كل
بطاقه الاقتراع قد يستغرق ايامك
هناك مساله اخرى وهي التصويت عبر البريد
بعض الولايات تفرز صنادقها مبكرا قبل يوم
الانتخابات لقد يرجح حزب على اخر وبعض
ولايات اخرى قد لا تبدا العده الا في نفس
يوم الانتخابات لذا فرز وتحديد الاصوات
بالبريد هي عمليه قد تستغرق اياما
[موسيقى]
في نفس هذا السياق كان اذى رئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب بصوته في الانتخابات
النصفيه في ولايه فلوريدا وقال ترامب انه
على الناخبين الادلاء باصواتهم واكد ضروره
الابقاء على سياسه اغلاق الخدود وخفض
الضرائب واضاف ترامب ان الثلاثاء المقبل
سيحمل اخبارا مثيره كما قال دون تصريح
بعزمه الترشح للانتخابات المقبله
ولكن الاهم ان تصوطه انها انتخابات مهمه
جدا هو اتمنى ان يحدث الصواب اعتقد ان اول
شيء يجب التركيز عليه هو الجريمه هو تخفيض
الضرائب لدينا اكبر ضرائب في التاريخ
وسيواصل الديمقراطيون رفعها ويجب اغلاق
الحدود ولذلك اعتقد انه من المهم مواصله
اغلاق الحدود وتخفيض الضرائب اعتقد ان
الثلاثاء المقبل سيحمل اخبار مثيره وتطلع
لرؤيتكم في مراكو